I've informed the BBC that I won't be
appearing on Match of the day tomorrow
night that's it one sentence who are
they going to get from Alan Shearer so
um it's well they've created quite a
battle for themselves
absolutely right they have handled this
so badly you know the lyrical story was
not leading Sky News it was leading the
BBC day after day it was extraordinary
it was as if they wanted to shoot
themselves in the foot or rather be seen
to be caving into this government
they've handled this so badly so who's
going to present match of the day
tomorrow and it I know look lots of
people don't follow football but lots of
people do care desperately about the BBC
and they want the BBC to be a public
sector of service broadcaster with a
rich variety of programs we're hearing
stories now about David mother David
attenborough's programs being taken off
because they were frightened of this
wretched government but there's a really
serious issue about the BBC and its
Sports coverage I mean goodness knows it
doesn't do much I mean people like like
Skye you'll be rubbing your hands with
Glenn the chance of getting writing
Shearer and of course and if the BBC
losers people like lilica frankly it
really doesn't have much else when it
comes to sport